hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're going to go
through the third of the previews for my
new a CT math review video course so if
that's something that you're interested
in purchasing it goes through sixty-five
concepts that are important and helpful
to know on the math section of the a CT
but we're going to do here is we're
going to go through a preview a sample
of what those lessons are like so if
you're interested check out the video
course I'll have links for that for you
in the meantime check out this video
I'll see you in the video ok in this
lesson we're going to talk about
midpoint so midpoint is definitely
something you want to know for the ECT
let's go over the formula and we'll go
through some examples so the midpoint
formula is X 1 plus X 2 divided by 2 and
y 1 plus y 2 divided by 2 so it's like
an average you're adding the x
coordinates of the two points the two
endpoints and dividing by 2 and then
you're adding the Y coordinates of the
two points and divided by 2 and that's
how you find the middle or the average
so for example here if we have the
points 1/4 and 3/8 okay I just kind of
draw a diagram like this we're trying to
find the midpoint 1 plus 3 is 4 divided
by 2 and 4 plus 8 is 12 divided by 2 so
you can see this is going to be 2 comma
6 is the location of the midpoint so
let's do a couple examples go ahead and
pause the video so you can practice on
your own and then we can go ahead and do
these together so and check your answer
if M is the midpoint of segment BC and
the coordinates of point B are 2
negative 6 and the coordinates of point
M okay our a negative 1 and negative 9
what are the coordinates of point C
that's the other end point so see if we
can do that one on your own so the way I
would do this is I would draw kind of
like a diagram something like this okay
so here's your midpoint here's B here's
C right we don't know the coordinates of
C so let's call that X Y B they tell us
the coordinates are 2 negative 6 and the
midpoint negative 1 negative 9 now don't
worry about this drawing being you know
accurate as far as in the coordinate
plane this is just to help us to
visualize so we know the midpoint but we
don't know the end point so what you
would do is you would add the two end
points together so we'd say X plus 2
divided by 2 ok so the average of the
axes equals negative 1
and then the average of the Y's y plus
negative six divided by two equals the y
coordinate of the midpoint all you have
to do then is solve these little mini
equations by multiplying let's see both
sides by two so that's X plus two equals
negative two subtract two from both
sides you get x equals negative four
same thing here multiply both sides by
two that gives you Y minus six and then
if you add six to both sides you get
negative twelve so you can see your
answer is going to be negative 4 or
negative twelve and if you want to
double check your work just go ahead and
add these together and divide by two so
negative four plus two is negative two
divided by two is negative one and so on
let's go to example number two so if
your school is two blocks east and four
blocks north of your home and your gym
is three blocks west and two blocks
south of your home and your favorite
restaurant is halfway between your gym
and school where is the restaurant
located in relation to your house so see
if you can do this problem on your own
and we'll do it together so the first
thing that I would do here is I would
draw a coordinate axis system so I would
like coordinate eyes these locations to
turn them into coordinates and you can
draw this as north east south west so
north east south west like so and so
basically your let's say your house is
right here at the origin and you're
going to blocks east in four blocks
north so two East and four north so
there's 2 comma 4 and that represents
let's see your school right so I'll just
put s for school and then your gym is
three blocks west into two blocks south
right so one two three and two south so
that's that negative 3 negative 2 that's
the gym right ok and your favorite
restaurant is halfway between the gym
and the school ok so we're basically
looking for the midpoint so when they
say halfway notice they didn't come
right out and tell us it was the
midpoint but halfway is is the midway
right so all we're going to do is use
our midpoint formula we're going to add
negative three plus two divided by two
so I'm adding the x-coordinates together
and dividing by two ok same thing with
the Y's we've got 4 plus negative two
divided by two and that's our midpoint
so that's going to be
negative 1/2 and this is going to be 2
over 2 which is 1 now in the context of
this problem in relation to your home
that's going to be a half a block west
in one block north
so I'll just say 1/2 block west and one
block north and that would be R solution
so this is a little tricky problem about
this is that you just had to coordinate
eyes the points draw this northeast
Southwest axis so that you could locate
where those were in relation to your
home and you place your home at the
origin but after you got it coordinate
eise's such using the midpoint formula
straight pretty straightforward so
midpoints definitely something you want
to know for the ECT memorize that
formula and I'll see you in the next
lesson